de vivir sus culturas
aquí en nuestra ciudad pensamos distinto
hasta hablan distintos herencia ahora
dos países una complejidad adicional
irán a invertir
[Música]
y nos planteamos un proyecto distinto
planteamos haciendo de una forma
completamente diferente porque si los
resultados que se estaban viendo
[Música]
formamos un humano distinto con soldados
el equipo político humano
más sentado a trabajar en el ser humano
que se llamó la organización y
trabajamos tres días
con una sencilla
[Música]
los tres pilares del proyecto fue la
simplicidad
instantes naturales de simplicidad uno
piensa que simplicidad de ocupación está
como personal y vida como ha hecho en la
carrera pero con simplicidad no es eso
mucho menos en el mundo nuevo sin medida
tiene que ver con encontrar la esencia
de las cosas en este momento mismo en
ciudad e información de aplicaciones
mientras estamos acá sentados
estamos desde crear 150.000 cosas estas
dos aplicaciones los otros 20 entidades
son acciones que tenemos podemos decir
de lo que realmente es importante pero
en la esencia de las cosas tiene
perdernos en medio de tantas cosas
accidentales cuando realmente cada cosa
tiene alguien es fundamental pienso que
va a ser realmente el resultado es
extraordinario
entonces lo primero que trabajamos con
la simplicidad
lo segundo que trabajamos son las
conexiones entre las personas y cuando
la colección está tienen peores
debidamente colectividades un vuelo
poder hablar las personas que están a
kilómetros de distancia usando tantas
herramientas que hoy día tantas cosas
cortantes noticia en un mapa estructural
lo que piense como el carbón con quién y
cómo se debe hablar cuales en una
comunicación y tantas cosas complejas
que relación inventando las
organizaciones pero tal vez tienes
también este proyecto que hicimos y sin
usar más fácil algo más definitivo y fue
simplemente habla también la parte más
primitiva de la comunicación de las
colecciones de los seres humanos es
hablar es mirar de los ojos este
proyecto se realizó en una finca donde
la gente vivía y trabajaba
[Música]
y más allá estarán podemos ver lo que
cultivamos lo que le preocupaba al otro
y podemos ir creando sinergias y del
ideario expectativas repetidos entonces
muchas veces nos complicamos para tratar
de comunicarnos para tratar de
conectarnos y olvidamos cosas tan
básicas como simplemente hablan entre es
el pilar fundamental y trabajamos en
este proyecto que trabaja con el corazón
este tipo de procesos involucran un
reconocimiento a la complejidad alta
entonces se busca de expertos con mucha
experiencia con un reconocimiento y
muchas horas de vuelo para que puedan
ante los colectivos que las compañías
tienen sin estar con este proyecto
formamos un equipo donde prima más el
ser humano el conocimiento y la
experiencia incluso una persona india
experta en el tema para ti si nos
ofreció hacer un fracaso porque tenía
gente muy joven gente sin tanta
experiencia el equipo se enteró de que
intentaba hacer un proyecto con el
fracaso y eso generó algo más de
interior emoción interna a cada persona
le generó logrando solamente cumplir los
objetivos si no luchamos esperar nos
entró mucho entonces logró generar una
cocina tradicional y de emoción
[Música]
y ese equipo dando esas entonces con
esos industrias finales se logró hacer
un proyecto distinto
todos los demás organizaciones
obviamente las entidades más importantes
en este tipo de proyectos
[Música]
los presupuestos se duplican
pasado un tiempo de estabilización de
maduración donde fácilmente
[Música]
el tiempo
este proyecto es muy importante proyecto
una forma distinta de ver las cosas que
se pueden organizar
a otras personas y esas personas y otros
proyectos
y esos años si aún no ayudándole a las
compañías de la organización
si estoy en lo que es empresarial muy
organizacional lo llevamos a la vida
nuestra seguramente que es más ya se
decía antes humanos encontramos
posibilidades de hacer cosas grandes por
todos
nos quedamos
un poquito antes
[Aplausos]